foreign
bugs
think of them as Nature's tiny engineers
because they come up with the most
extraordinary and incredible solutions
to Life's problems and I just love
observing them because they're so full
of surprises and Curiosities
during my career I studied spiders that
use their webs as a slingshot to capture
prey deep in the Amazon rainforest worms
that tangle up with each other and form
knots to form these shape-shifting blobs
to survive in harsh environments such as
sewers and caves and Tiny aquatic
beetles that bring their own scuba gear
when they dive on their butts
but today I'm going to tell you a story
about one of Nature's most extraordinary
Engineers that pushes the limits of
fluid mechanics and bioengineering and
arguably solves their number one problem
how insects be
a few years ago my student elyuchilida
and I observed this tiny insect having a
private moment in our own backyards in
Atlanta and we couldn't believe our eyes
this insect was being for hours and it
was so quick we could barely see it and
we were blown away we had never seen
anything like this we had never seen an
insect bee so today I'm gonna tell you
how insects B
why they pee so much and in this way and
finally why you should care about insect
be so sit back and relax you're in for a
treat
[Applause]
so one of the first things we had to
discuss is wait a second in sex B and
turns out that almost all insects be in
one form or the other it's a closed
system what goes in must come out but
the protagonist of today's story
homologous Bennis or a glass-earing
sharpshooter isn't it gorgeous you can
see what it gets its name from it's got
these transparent wings and this insect
specializes in feeding on xylem fluid
from Plants it's a sap sucker but I
think of it as a plant's mosquito and
just after a mosquito sucks your blood
it leaves behind a parting gift so do
these Sharpshooters that spread bacteria
into these plants and it causes
devastating and deadly diseases in
Plants killing them this is a huge
problem in agriculture including here in
California where they cost millions of
dollars in damage to Vineyards and you
can appreciate what they lack in size
they make up in numbers this is what
millions of insects feeding and peeing
looks like if only this woman knew where
that water was coming from
now don't worry this insect speed is
just water and so for the first time I'm
gonna show you this Behavior slowed down
with our high speed cameras and this is
what we discovered we realized that this
insect forms a droplet of p and then it
flings them at extreme accelerations of
40G forces that's 40 times faster than
the Sprint of a cheetah these insects
are really packing a punch from their
butts and we wanted to under
so we put this
in a microscope at its business end and
this beautiful structure has a
scientific name it's called a butt
flicker
all right
and this is what we discovered we
realized that this insect had evolved
Springs and latches just like a catapult
so that it could efficiently hurl its
droplets of pee repeatedly at these high
accelerations now we wanted to measure
the speed at which this flicker was
moving and the droplets so we measured
the speed of both the droplets and the
Flicker and this is where we made a
puzzling observation the speed of the
droplets in air was faster than the
flicker so if you take a ratio of that
we were expecting it to be a hundred
percent but turns out that the speed of
the droplets are about 150 to 200
percentage faster than the flicker
itself this is why this is
counterintuitive imagine a Yankees
baseball player throwing a ball at 100
miles an hour
at some point during that throw their
hands and fingers are moving at 100
miles an hour say an amateur ball player
throws a ball at 50 miles an hour and if
you measure the speed of the ball and
it's 100 miles an hour in mid-air we'd
be surprised where would that extra
Speed come from right
this is exactly what these insects are
doing so to solve this puzzle we went
back and looked at our videos and we'll
play this a couple of times and see if
you can figure this out
did he catch it
let me grab a frame we realized that
unlike a baseball that's rigid these
droplets due to surface tension these
tiny droplets are squishy
and we had an aha moment we're wondering
if this insect is storing energy due to
the surface tension just before launch
and to test this we did naturally what
any of us would do we converted our
kitchen tables into a lab to test this
so now we're going to place droplets on
a speaker to squish them at high speeds
and this is what we discovered
we realized that water that flows in our
faucets like a liquid at these tiny
scales due to surface tension with the
right timing can get a kick store energy
and if you time it just right you can
launch these off at extremely high
speeds just like a child on a trampoline
and to test this idea of timing we even
built a catapult or should I say
a cat of B
and it reinforced this idea to slow the
droplets don't go off and then if you
move at the right speed you flung this
so I've told you today
how these insects use the scaffolding
structure to store energy in surface
tension and throw these droplets at
record-breaking speeds to be really
number one
at number one
but why have these insects of all this
remarkable ability and there are two
reasons for this number one is they're
on a zero calorie diet these tiny bugs
are feeding from the xylem fluid that
comes up through the roots through the
soil and goes to the rest of the plants
it's very very poor in nutrients it's
just water and some minerals this is
unlike the phloem fluid which is rich in
Sugar coming through photosynthesis at
the leaves and going through the rest of
the plants this is akin to a human
purely sustain themselves on a diet of
diet lemonade
very low energy source you'd have to
constantly drink but you'd have to
constantly pee as well this still
doesn't explain why these insects be in
droplets and not in Jets like you and I
would if you were to take a buy a break
let's take a look at cicadas these are
the cousins of these Sharp Shooters they
are also xylem fluid feeders
and they pee in Jets
I love this video These shows cicadas
doing two of their favorite things when
they come out of hibernation singing at
the top of their lungs and being in the
Wind
and the second reason for why these
insects being droplets is size these
things are tiny they're smaller than my
pinky
in fact surface tension that enables
them to store energy in these droplets
to launch is actually an impediment
because gravity doesn't matter and
surface engine sticks these droplets to
their bodies so they actually have to
flick these droplets away it's actually
very difficult for these tiny bugs to
pee and that's why I just love studying
bugs this tiny engineer has figured out
to survive
on barely just watered through this
nylon fluid and it's figured out to do
so it has to drink a lot and pee a lot
in that sense it's not so different from
other Engineers I know on a Friday night
at a bar
but to do so it's figured out this it
has to evolve this catapulting structure
and fling these droplets at high speeds
and that's why I always tell my students
when we explore new bugs it's not a bug
it's a feature
[Applause]
should you care about insect being
what's a practical application of this
work maybe maybe one day these ideas
these principles could help us design
more efficient water ejector systems so
our smartphones our watches and hearing
aids but I have to be honest
that's not really why I obsess over
insect B for the last four years
I do this
because when I share my work
with kids it ignites their curiosity
when I talk about insect feet makes
their eyes light up
they laugh they run around in their
backyards looking at bugs and asking
questions it reminds them and us
that we can discover marvelous in the
mundane Even in our own backyards we
just have to look closely
thank you so much
[Music]
I gotta go pee